que vous dire j'ai une roue ici qui
s'appelle la roue des soldes vous êtes
tous payé aujourd'hui
mais il ya aujourd'hui il y a ou des
mois 70 % ou 1 25 ou plus 50 % sur votre
salaire du jour je vais faire tourner la
roue il ya plus de moins que plus
illusion d'optique
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous dire c'est normal c'est les
soldes d'accord alors qu'est veut
parfois aussi p matthieu delormeau donc
votre salaire on sait de combien il est
vrai vous je vais tourner la roue ouais
je serai alors franchement je le fais
normalement
d'accord d'accord en très cher sans
triche mais le premier vous pouvez vrai
prix pour qui à toi pour un tunisien
chantal à tunisiens alors du racisme
dans cette année c'est ça du racisme
dans cette émission
bravo ben haïm ramon
[Applaudissements]
brabant tout de suite je lance ce
hashtag elle est belle la france à ben
haim un bien sûr elle est belle mais
riche en talent pour la peine je n'ai
joué qu'en dit d'accord alors d'abord
bâtir évident à y aller
ah bon c'est super bien ça aide beaucoup
alors voilà bon alors c'est vous amadu
tire très fort très fort je me serais
même pas que vous parlez comme ça j'ai
oublié car s'il vous plaît non alors je
tire très fort et très fort et est
éloignée et huppée avec vous lui quand
il fait l'amour c'est comme dans
d'autres elle est maire de troyes ac est
allé je connais la roue si on tient très
fort non là je suis vraiment cognon
déjanté attention - sans presque
matthieu delormeau et je le fais
vraiment si c'est du moins ça sera
reversé à un tweet hausse bien sûr
porto
[Applaudissements]
hu à 90% sur son siège unique il est
très bien payé et mathieu narbonne donc
allez-y acheté personne pour récupérer
pour récupérer la somme de matthieu
delormeau le premier tweet ou sly prend
les 90% le match normal et battu des
joueuses avaient dit et vous nous avez
insisté
géraldine mallet ya ce sera tout sauf un
grand plaisir
[Rires]
oui et non j'ai rajouté géraldine
maillet géré alors c'est le salaire de
géraldine maillet ce qu'il va y avoir un
maxime galy voulez vous n'êtes pas payé
au maxi comment je tire avec panache
excuse moi tu dit ça il m est ce que tu
veux ou fasse l'amour avec panache allez
c'est parti
c'était comme ça quand il était sur vous
exactement s'il n'y a jamais rien eu
entre nos jours était au courant me dit
tout à améliorer ça veut dire elle a une
maladie voyage des quelqu'un dit quelque
chose
alors je me dis comment ça se fait que
tu aurais pas de pâtir ils n'ont pas du
tout à le ciel
attention je suis le bouc a menacé
[Applaudissements]
wallerand de saint just à leur égard
quant à elle adore détester bien avait
raison il ya dépensé bien fait n'était
pas bien j'ai pris une photo de moi on
doit voter blanc les bus d'accord je
découvre l'émission mais j'ai des
nausées je me sens pas bien quoi vous
ben oui alors il faut savoir qu'elle est
payée en anciens francs
elle est payée en est qu en coupant la
paix un humour la 2e tour à tour ah oui
ça va ça pour l'heure aulas
mais je reverse à tous alors http sol
pour récupérer les salaires on enfin dix
derniers mois des neiges de rire la
ligue 1
hk si vous voulez je peux le faire pour
moi vaut le coup géraldine géraldine à
payer vous il ya deux cent mille euros
pour à twickenham
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour moi aussi j'étais membre
aussi du coeur directement alors là ce
soir c'est pour un twittos ce à quoi bon
un besoin du championnat qui va prendre
le salaire 90% de leurs mots 30% de rue
attention quand même y avait là j'ai
raté vous voulez le faire
non je fais confiance tirée pour vous
même mais j'ai déjà fait ce rallye je
tiens pour moi oui elle vit à laizy
attention à toi tu attends une marine au
centre kelly alors qu'elle est avec le
vol il va faire plus 100 % en mai mais
justement sur ça que ce sac est alors de
quelle manière
qu'est ce qui vous le chantez aa avec
délicatesse os aval au témiscouata fait
pour nous avec doigté avait teint plus
ces cieux il a une bonne bouille à une
heure non non non non sûr que c'est un
stress angoisse je serais très inquiet
attentats
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
blais
bien sûr je reverse 50% +1 tweetos bien
entendu la bonne je vous avais une
nation une bordée de noël on a le cul
bordé de nouilles team merci mamie